m
ceci est l'empreinte terrano or acc qui
datent de 66 millions d'années c'est pas
le pied du dehors mais plutôt sans
empreintes fossilisées qu'il a c'est
l'impact de son pied dans l'eure
notez bien ce rôle l'impact ne vous
inquiétez surtout pas je suis pas alain
tanner
je suis pas ici pour parler de l'ère
jurassique
je vais plus tous vous faire voyager
dans le temps de quelques années
seulement on est en 1991 si moi j'ai
disons à cette époque je savais
exactement ce que je voulais faire une
fois encore je voulais voyager en jet
privé pour coiffer leurs pépins pour
sauver le monde pour arrêter les
platines pour stopper dtn pour éradiquer
la pauvreté
c'était la personne nous disons
maintenant voilà en deux minutes
je viens pour tailler mes études en
attribue rit on this l'information j'ai
aussi un métier un métier des plus
passionnants lorsque j'ai fait ce que je
faisais serre mais il y avait un
problème à court
j'ai pas réaliser mes rêves j'ai 24
victimes par définition la non réussite
d'abord matin des objectifs c'est
l'échec avec ça le petit garçon de 10
ans a échoué il a échoué lamentablement
j'avais deux choix faire des nantais la
partition en sort ou bien essayer de
faire quelque chose pour se vendre comme
elle mais cette fois ci dit vous pour ce
faire j'ai décidé d'appliquer les
enseignements trois principes pouvait
lire trois piliers qui le premier
principe et une séance de cours est une
expérience partagée rend dans la maison
quant à ma deuxième principe c'était
éviter les divisions éviter les
diapositives surchargé de la table à
donner aux étudiants ce dont ils ont
besoin
allez droit au but au troisième incident
c'était le plus important à mes yeux
c'est vrai il n'y a pa ta yo
il n'y a pas de mauvais éléments chacun
d'autant tiers j'ai foutu et comme ça ma
grippe aura des principes donnant un
tour atypique que c'est pâques décoller
aux rebelles
à côté de la plaque en tout cas les
étudiants le savourer ils ont donc pour
des buses vous avez un bon cd on ne fait
pas penser des biopsies de larouche âge
j'en ai fait j'ai créé un très bon
appétit nos peuples aussi qu'ils sont
les états technique sans entrer dans les
détails techniques pour constituer une
meilleure solution pour développer des
applications web européenne
j ai participé à des conférences en
tunisie au maroc algérie pour exposer
les femmes les encourageant à repousser
un ventre et coloré de la plus grande
conférence javaone la jama
la surprise est venue alors j'écris j'ai
pris à napier suis allé à san francisco
quelconque vive qu'elle peut réussir là
bas j'ai trouvé les des gérances mondial
en double j'ai défini cité j'ai été
applaudi qui tenait m'interviewer ci et
non plus leur club est plein de
références dans plus si lentement ça
fait plaisir mais ce qui vous touche et
plus vendre et c'est vraiment autre
chose
je rappelle toujours de certains de mes
rencontres avec les étudiants et qui me
disait monsieur chic et maîtrise c'est
au pas faux pas qui m'ont poussé à débat
n'est pas stable monsieur je suis kif
technical officer et ses parcours qui
m'a fait et les poussions tracteur
monsieur recréer un groupe on participe
à des projets ressources parce que
monsieur vous êtes la preuve vivante que
nous tunisiens on peut faire voyez ces
paroles et quelques-uns de ses compères
pour les réseaux sociaux j'ai dû gérer
on fait que le venger et conviction chez
conviction que je voudrais partager sur
le chemin de l'irréalisable même si vous
n'atteignez pas un objectif mais si vous
réalisez pas vos rêves vous pouvez
parfois sans même vouloir influencer des
hôtes un impact énorme sur le chemin de
la possible
vous pouvez toujours planté des graines
que toutes les générations futures entre
mondialement
et rien ne peut être un objectif de
départ n'est pas de choquer n'était pas
de son fait mais en cdl demande de
vouloir faire exactement comme ce qu'a
fait ce jeudi rex 66 millions d'années a
laissé matin avoir à la pâte sur son
environnement et j'ai réussi
justement en tout cas et à votre entité
j'aimerais vous parler de quelque chose
toujours à propos du jeu madden
impossible car la bière m'a fait du jury
pour une pause diplômes et de petite
fille un buisson qui peut te crache vous
restera prenant leur père pourtant peu
piège becker et si bien
[Applaudissements]